welcome back to harbor unboxed today we
are
finally able to check out the geforce
rtx
3070 this is nvidia's latest mid-range
geforce offering targeting the 500
us price range and i would like to
dedicate this review to our good mate
kevin from tech showdown he tragically
passed away
very suddenly this time last year and
we've had
the australian cousin of kevin's teddy
in the background
ever since yeah but yeah we we missed
the guy a lot
especially around new releases like this
as kevin would share in the excitement
with us
[Music]
okay so last month we sort of saw the
arrival of the rtx 3080 and the rtx 3090
i mean we got to show you the benchmarks
and a few cards all that sort of stuff
but
it seems as though very few of you were
able to buy one
we're almost six weeks now from the
initial release of the rtx 3080 and
availability is still virtually
non-existent
which frankly isn't good enough and it's
looking very much like nvidia has
botched this release
we have heard various stories within the
industry that this might have been
planned a way to drive up pricing so
once supply does start to flow people
will be well adjusted to prices above
msrp
it all sounds a bit crazy but then we
saw exactly that with the geforce rtx
2080 ti
which in reality was never a one
thousand dollar us product
instead coming in at more like twelve
hundred dollars us or more
and pricing other regions like here in
australia was heavily inflated
so for nvidia time really is running out
whether this is a deliberate action or
just a gross miscalculation of demand
the brand is taking a hit the backlash
from games is more extreme than we ever
imagined it would be
and perhaps it's a situation where
nvidia didn't foresee the backlash
either
whatever the case the failure of the
3080 and 3090 launch has put the more
affordable rtx 3070 in a bit of a rough
spot
it was initially slated for release on
the 15th of october
however having witnessed just how poorly
the lack of availability
was received by gamers nvidia wisely
opted to push the 3070 release back by
two weeks to the 29th of october
allowing them to build up a larger
stockpile for release day
so hopefully your chances of buying an
rtx 3070 in two days time when they hit
shelves on the 29th
are going to be much higher and we're
really hoping to see strong availability
within
three to four weeks after release but so
far that does seem unlikely given what
we've seen with the 3080 and 3090.
now while you pray for improved
availability of these parts
we have a video sponsor today's video
sponsor is be quiet and their brand new
line of pure loop high performance
liquid coolers available in 120
240 280 and 360 millimeter radiator
versions
using purewings two pwm fans a really
interesting design aspect of the pure
loop is the doubly decoupled pump which
isn't situated in the cpu block but
rather in the tubes
near the radiator and this design
minimizes vibration and therefore
reduces the operating volume the cpu
block features a minimalistic design to
suit all builds and with the nickel
plated cold plate can be used with
liquid metal and to ensure longevity the
loop is also serviceable with an easy to
access refill port and bquite even
includes a coolant bottle in the kit
so for more information please check the
link in the video description
so moving on from horror availability
let's quickly talk about the rtx 3070
before jumping into all the benchmark
data
whereas the 3080 and 3090 share the same
ga 102 die
the 3070 is based on the almost 40
percent smaller ga 104 die
it packs 32 percent fewer cuda cores and
tmus with the same
96 rops that said the cores are clocked
higher though we're only talking about a
four percent increase for the base clock
and a percentage for the boost clock
the memory subsystems also been
downgraded firstly we're moving away
from 10 gigabytes of high-speed gddr6x
memory
to eight gigabytes of standard 14
gigabits per second
gddr6 and with a narrower 256 bit wide
memory bus this does limit the peak
bandwidth to
448 gigabytes per second still despite
those downgrades nvidia has claimed that
the rtx 3070
is on par with the rtx 2080 ti
though of course it is missing three
gigabytes of vram but at 500
us at least that's the claimed msrp
it is worlds cheaper than the rtx 2080
ti so if it delivers similar performance
that will be a bit of a big deal
now an advantage of the cut down design
is the much lower tdp rating
of 220 watts that's 100 watts lower than
the 3080 and 30 watts lower than the
outgoing 2080 ti
this should mean that 3070 based
graphics cards will be cool
quiet and easier on your power supply so
we'll look into that later on in the
review
but for now that's about everything we
want to talk about it's time to get into
the blue bar graphs
for testing we're using our ryzen 9
3950x test system
featuring four sticks of low latency
ddr4 3200
cl 14 memory kicking off the benchmarks
with death stranding at 1440p
we indeed find rtx 2080ti light
performance from the new 3070
pumping at 134 fps on average
when compared to the similarly priced
2070 super that is a 30
performance boost and a 24 increase from
the 5700 xt
so a lot less impressive in terms of
cost per frame compared to amd's 5700
series at least in this title
even at 4k the 3070 is seen matching the
2080 ti with 83 fps on average
making it just shy of 30 percent slower
than the 30 80.
so that's a good result overall for a
gpu said to cost just 500
us next up we have microsoft flight
simulator 2020 and here the 3070 again
matched the 2080 ti
in fact we're not even talking about
2080 ti light performance at 1440p
but rather exactly 2080 ti performance
the 3070 does drop off a little bit at
4k and this is likely due to only having
8 gigabytes of vram
but the performance hit isn't massive
but flight simulator 2020 will be
pushing beyond the 8 gigabyte capacity
with the ultra quality settings at 4k
and as a result the rtx 3070 pays a
small performance penalty
i'm starting to sense a trend here again
we're looking at
very similar performance to that of the
2080 ti at 1440p
this time in shutoff the tomb raider
that means we're looking at about a 30
performance increase for nvidia at the
500 us price point
when compared to the 2070 super and 55
from the vanilla 2070
again we see that the 3070 slips behind
slightly at 4k
here vram usage hits around seven and a
half to eight gigabytes so it's possible
we're on the edge of a vram capacity
limitation here
or the tiny performance it could be due
to memory bandwidth either way we're
only talking about the 3070 being a few
frames down on the 2080 ti
tom clancy's rainbow six siege makes
heavy use of compute
and this hands the ampere architecture
and advantage a very small advantage
over touring but it does help
as a result the rtx 3070 was five
percent faster than the 2082 at 1440p
and 44 faster than the 2070 super
the 3070 also remains strong at 4k again
edging out the 2080 ti by a few frames
making it 21
slower than the 3080 but 47 faster than
the 2070 super
moving on to f1 2020 again we're looking
at 2080 ti light performance from the
3070 making it 34
faster than the 2070 super but just 19
faster than the 5700 xt the rtx 3070
slips a few frames behind the 2080 ti at
4k
but we're talking about just a 2fps
margin here
so the same performance then that meant
the 3070 was almost 40
faster than the 2070 super but just 30
percent faster than the 5700 xt
we're seeing more of the same in gears 5
the 3070 was able to match the 2080 ti
actually it was 3 fps faster here but
again we're talking about basically the
same performance
though we are only looking at a 27 boost
over the 2070 super
and slightly less over the 5700 xt
at 4k the 3070 again matched the 2080 ti
and that meant it was 33 percent faster
than the 2070 super
and almost 40 percent faster than the
5700 xt
interestingly the rtx 3070 was eight
percent faster than the 2082 at 1440p
and horizon zero dawn delivering 96 fps
on average
and that made it 45 percent faster than
the 2070 super
and 37 faster than the 5700 xt
so a solid result here performance for
the 3070 remained very strong at 4k
as here it was 10 faster than the 2080
ti and a whopping 51 percent faster than
the 2070 super
moving on to assassin's creed odyssey
and you guessed it
2080 ti light performance at 1440p the
gains over the 2070 super are very weak
in this title
at least when using a third gen ryzen
processor we're talking about just a 14
increase there's no cpu bottleneck to be
seen at 4k
and as a result the 3070 was 39 faster
than the 2070 super
and even managed to beat the 2080 ti by
a nine percent margin so
quite an impressive result we're seeing
a small performance boost over the 2080
ti at 1440p
with four percent more frames on average
though interestingly we do see an eight
percent increase to the one percent low
result anyway that meant the 3070 was 38
faster than the 2070 super and 36
percent faster than the 5700 xt
then jumping up to 4k sees the 3070
running just a single frame ahead of the
2080 ti
so once again we're looking at 2080 ti
light performance
and this meant that while the 3070 was
25 slower than the 3080
it was almost 40 percent fast in the
2070 super
next up we have metro exodus and the
results here are a little unexpected as
the 3070 trailed the 2080 ti by a seven
percent margin
and that meant it was just 16 faster
than the 2070 super at 1440p
the 4k data is just as unexpected here
the 3070 gets close to the average frame
rate of the 2080 ti
but it is well down on the one percent
low performance only matching the 2080
super
the resident evil 3 results are more
what we've come to expect the 3070 is
seen delivering very similar performance
that of the 2080 ti
here it was just three percent slower at
1440p
the rtx 3070 drops off a little further
at 4k here it was six percent slower so
not a terrible result
and it was still 39 faster than the 2070
super
moving on to the do maternal results and
here we see that the 30 70 is seven
percent slower than the 2080 ti at 1440p
which is a little surprising to see in
this title
that said we're still talking about an
almost 40 performance boost over the
2070 super
and 35 over the 5700 xt
now at 4k using the ultra nightmare
textures which does call for nine
gigabytes of vram
we find that the 3070 falls further
behind the 2080 ti
now trailing by a 14 margin but other 8
gigabyte models like the 2070 super also
suffer here and as a result the higher
memory bandwidth of the 3070 plays a
more crucial role
allowing it to beat the 2070 super by a
margin however if you lower the texture
quality to ultra which only requires
seven gigabytes of vram
the 3070 is now able to match the 2080
ti
rendering 141 fps on average
the second last game tested is
wolfenstein youngblood and here we're
seeing the 3070 match the 2080 ti
almost exactly making it 21 slower than
the 3080 and 38 percent faster than the
2070 super
then at 4k the rtx 3070 was three
percent sold than the 28 hci and
26 percent slower than the 3080 but it
was also 37
faster than the 2070 super last up we
have hitman 2
and you guessed it 2080 ti light
performance at 1440p
we do see the 3070 drop off slightly at
4k
here it was just four percent slow in
the 2080 ti but 55
faster than the 2070 super okay so i
think it is safe to say that the rtx
is very much delivering 2080 ti like
performance as promised by nvidia
so that was good to see and in a moment
we will move to look at some
head-to-head comparisons with the 3080
2080 ti 2070 super and 5700 xt
but before that here is a look at the
average fps data
across the 14 game sample although i
didn't show the 1080p data here i did
collect it and i'll make those results
available to patreon members
but for everybody else i do have the 14
game average data to share
and as you can see the 3070 is basically
a 2080 ti averaging 185 fps on average
across all the games tested that meant
on average at 1080p the rtx 3070 is 26
faster than the 5700 xt and 27 faster
than the 2070 super
while it was also just 12 percent slower
than the rtx 3080.
moving on to 1440p this sees the rtx
3070 beat the 5700 xt by 36
margin and the 2070 super by a 33
percent margin
while it was just 18 percent slow on the
rtx 3080.
oh and here it matched the 2080 ti
exactly
so once again we are now looking at 2080
ti performance
for 500 us then at 4k the 3070 slips a
few frames behind the 2080 ti due to
titles such as doom eternal but even so
it was still
38 faster than the 2070 super on average
and
48 faster than the 5700 xt which really
isn't a 4k gaming graphics card okay so
here's a breakdown between the 2080 ti
and 3070 at 1440p
as you can see the rtx 3070 does very
well in horizon zero dawn
and rainbow six siege while it is less
impressive in do maternal and metro
exodus
though we are only talking about a seven
percent margin here
basically at most we're looking at
single-digit percentage differences
between these two gpus
the 2080 ti does fare a little bit
better at 4k thanks to that extra 3
gigabytes of vram
though it really was only do maternal
with the ultra nightmare textures that
was an issue for the 3070 and its 8
gigabyte vram buffer
then compared to the rtx 3080 the 3070
was at most
26 percent slower seen in resident evil
while it was as little as 7 slower in
hitman 2 though here we are cpu limited
at 1440p
increasing the resolution of 4k removes
any and all cpu bottlenecks and here we
can see that the 3070 is between 19 and
37 slower than the rtx 3080 though we're
not limited by
vram capacity it's only up to 28
slower when compared to the rtx 2070
super
the product the 3070 is arguably
replacing
we're looking at a 31 performance boost
on average at 1440p
with margins as high as 45 as seen in
horizon zero dawn
then at 4k we're seeing that the 3070 is
on average 38
faster than the 2070 super which is
quite a substantial performance uplift
especially with gains as large as 50 in
doom eternal and horizon zero dawn
the comparison with the 5700 xt is
interesting as the 3070 was an average
fast 1440p which means in terms of cost
per frame
they should be very similar that said
for those targeting 4k the 3070 does
become
considerably better in terms of value as
here it was seen to be 47
faster than average and that is quite a
significant performance uplift
okay so here's a look at total system
consumption using our ryzen 9 3950x test
system
the rtx 3070 pushed total system usage
to 371 watts
and under the same conditions the 2080
ti reached 433 watts which
means the 3070 consumed 14 percent less
power
it also used almost 30 less power than
the rtx 3080
and we're also looking at a similar
power draw to the rtx 2070 super
so a very efficient gpu indeed
using pcat to measure the power draw of
just the graphics card
we see the 3070 consumed just six what's
more or three percent more power
than the 2070 super and 10 less than the
5700 xt
we're also looking at a 31 reduction
when compared to the 3080
and 14 less than the 2080 ti
what this means is in terms of
performance per watt the geforce rtx
3070 is now the most efficient graphics
card we've ever tested
delivering nine percent more performance
per watt than the rtx 3080
and 17 more per watt than the 2080 ti
it's also 59 more efficient than the 7
nanometer radeon rx 5700 xt
so it will be interesting to see how amd
can improve on that shortly
in a few days time i'll be taking a look
at some custom
aib 3070s and i'll be comparing them to
nvidia's founders edition
with a detailed look at vrm and gddr6x
memory temperatures but in the meantime
here is a quick look at how the rtx 3070
founders edition
ran after an hour in shadow of the tomb
raider the gpu peaked at just 72 degrees
with a fan speed of 1650 rpm which is
very reasonable
and here the card was very quiet the
average clock speed scene in this test
was 1890 megahertz
so just shy of 1.9 gigahertz and of
course the memory operated at 14
gigabits per second
just quickly here's a look at
overclocking headroom with the fe model
i was able to get the cores to a maximum
frequency of 1805 megahertz which is a
measly four percent overclock
but with the increased power budget and
fourteen percent boost to memory
bandwidth i did see an eight percent
increase in fps when testing a shot of
the tomb raider at 1440p
now here's a look at cost per frame
starting with the 1440p
data as you can see the rtx 3070 is now
the best value graphics card
in terms of cost per frame coming out
seven percent cheaper
compared to the standard rx 5700 and
25 more cost effective than the 2070
super
basically you're now getting rtx 2080 ti
performance for well under half the
price
as we don't recognize the 1 000 us msrp
for the 2080 ti
that was basically a lie with most
models selling for 1200
us or more the cost per frame is a
little more reliable
at 4k as here we're removing any and all
system bottlenecks
even so the rtx 3070 still comes out on
top
just beating the rtx 3080 this meant it
was 27
cheaper per frame than the 2070 super so
a much better value proposition
at the 500 us price point something
nvidia has made a
big deal of with their new amp
architecture is their so-called
second generation of rt cores and third
generation tensor cores
they claim that right triangle insertion
throughput is now
doubled so that the rt core delivers
39.7 rt teraflops compared to turing's
23.8
they also claim that the new tensor core
automatically identifies and removes
less important
dnn weights and the new hardware
processes the sparse network at twice
the rate of
turing tensor 162.610
with sparsity compared to turing's 63
teraflops
so all of that should mean significantly
improved
ray tracing and dlss performance but as
we found previously with the rtx 3080
performance here was only improved over
the 2080 ti
because the 3080 was faster in terms of
raw performance
with the 3070 we now have an ampere gpu
with the same raw performance as the
2080 ti
so how do they compare in terms of rtx
performance starting with death
stranding at 1440p
we see that dlss performance is no
better with the rtx 3070 when compared
to the 2080 ti
there is literally no improvement to be
seen here
even at 4k we see a zero improvement in
dlss performance with the ampere gpu
even in f1 2020 we see very little
change although the 3070 was five
percent faster with dlss enabled when
compared to the 2080 ti
we're talking about a very small
increase moreover we saw
that margin completely evaporate at 4k
here the 3070 scales in line with the
2080 ti
then lastly we had a look at shadow of
the tomb raider and this gives us a look
at dlss
and ray tracing performance and when
compared to the 2080 ti
we see that the 3070 does nothing to
improve ray tracing or dlss performance
even at 4k there are no improvements to
be seen
with the so-called 2nd gen rt cores and
3rd gen tensor cores
so that is super disappointing to see
and that brings us towards the end of
our geforce rtx 3070 review
overall the 3070 it is a great value
product though i am a little tentative
to recommend you rush out and buy one
assuming good availability that is as we
know amd is set to make
their next gen big announcement roughly
this time tomorrow it'll be a few hours
after this video went live but
yeah not too long now and no doubt we'll
be able to provide you with reviews of
those products within a reasonable time
frame after that announcement
and that means in the very near future
the geforce 30 series will have
some kind of competition and it is
possible the rtx 3070 won't be the best
value option at 500
us of course we don't know just yet but
it's probably going to be one of those
cases where it's worth waiting
just a little bit you won't have to wait
too long and then you'll be able to make
a more informed purchase
still upcoming competition aside in
today's market the rtx 3070
is as good as it gets in terms of cost
per frame
and even performance per watt as i said
at 500 dollars it's a great value
product
offering performance that previously
cost more than one thousand dollars us
with an rtx 2080 ti
the 3070 really is the new and much more
affordable 2080 ti
with the exception of the missing three
gigabytes of vram performance is
basically identical which is both good
and a little bit disappointing depending
on what you're testing
obviously the raw gpu performance is
excellent matching the 2080 ti across
the board
it also matched the dlss and rt
performance which
i guess is good but also a bit
disappointing given in videos touting
second gen rt calls and
third gen tensor cores finding that
those claimed upgrades offer nothing new
in terms of performance was
disappointing
an advantage of the rtx 3070 is the
improved power consumption
shaving off about 60 watts means it's
possible to make more compact graphics
cards or larger models that run cooler
and quieter which is what we're likely
going to see from most aib models
i feel like normally i'd be a lot more
excited to see previous gen flagship
performance
available at the 500 price point or
alternatively
an almost 40 performance boost over the
previous 500
part in this case that would be the 2070
super
but given the lack of availability for
parts such as the rtx 3080
and comments from those in the industry
that suggests we may be looking at
another msrp bait and switch
akin to that of the 2080 ti i'm not
getting too excited just yet
it's extremely important in my opinion
that nvidia addresses the supply issue
as soon as possible and ensures that
base models
do hit the msrp otherwise it's going to
be
what's going to become very difficult
for reviewers and perhaps more
importantly you guys customers
to believe their msrp figures in the
future
so we'll just have to wait and see on
that one but as i said it's very
important that
nvidia does improve supply and make sure
that the msrps are hit
but anyway that is going to do it for
our rtx 3070 review
and again we would like to dedicate this
review to kevin
we very much miss him so maybe if you
can
jump over to kevin's channel tech
showdown and leave
a comment there i know his family will
be reading those
and yeah so that'd be really nice if you
could do that of course we we have teddy
back here as well
so yeah that that's gonna do it for this
one thank you very much for watching
i'm your host steve and i'll see you
again next time
[Music]
so
you